let's move on to our science critic okay
and uh this fellow
uh
he thinks that an explanation is just a
description
and so many people believe that in fact
all of mathematical physics on the one
hand they say well it's not a
description is not an explanation then
they say exactly the opposite they say
yeah the explanation in the end is just
a bunch of descriptions
so they haven't figured out the
difference between an explanation and a
description this is a problem okay so
let me turn this follow loose so that
you know what the issue is here goes pay
attention
the issue to be addressed in this
rebuttal is
is a description the same as an
explanation
now another thing that i take issue with
that he said is science only explains it
doesn't describe well i'm sorry
but a description can be an explanation
the only real difference between a
description and an explanation is a
description is describing how something
is an explanation is answering a
question so if you ask the question of
why is the sky blue you'll receive an
explanation of rayleigh scattering but
really scattering is a description of
what's happening there and that
description explains why the sky is blue
okay
so um he gives this example really uh
scattering and so if you look it up
you'll find same thing that i found and
i found it in hyperphysics here it is
and here you can see the difference
between a description and explanation
which this fellow did not understand i
mean on the one hand he says look one
answer is a question
but it's like
he didn't listen to what you were saying
okay so here's this is a description and
this comes all out of the same place
rayleigh scattering uh refers to the
scattering of light off of the molecules
of the air and can be extended to
scattering from particles up to about a
tenth of the wavelength of the light so
far all we have is an ex a description
we have no idea why the sky is blue so
far
okay all they're saying is that
molecules scatter light
that's a description right now we have
no explanation of anything now comes the
explanation of the mechanism of the
cause okay of what of why the sky is
blue it is rayleigh scattering off the
molecules of the air which give us the
blue sky and now you can go into more
detail and say look this is the
explanation of why what causes the sky
to be blue
but you cannot go with the first
paragraph there and say oh that
explained it explains why the sky is
blue so you can see a little bit of a
difference here and this is just in
general terms so you can see the
difference between a description and an
explanation like he says an explanation
answers a question a description does
not but he doesn't understand what he
said okay this is this is
so you wonder about his mental state or
what is going through that you know
between his ears he's got very little to
block the information that's going
through there anyways here uh let me
give you an example okay another example
this is uh referring to the rope okay
here it is here's a picture or a movie
right of two atoms bound by the rope
so far you have no explanation so far
all we've got is a description it's an
illustration and you can say okay two
atoms they're apparently expanding and
contracting and there's a rope between
them that's a description so far unless
i give you some background talking
behind and tell you what you're staring
at
what this is all about you don't have
any idea that that rope uh torquing
there is supposed to represent light
okay now uh you know i constantly say
that you need to make movies of your
physical interpretations okay because a
picture if a picture's worth uh
a thousand words a movie is worth a
million words okay so so keep that in
mind but the issue here is very simple
is um i'm uh on the one hand giving you
a description of the mechanism but
unless i tell you what i'm trying to
explain what i'm trying to answer
you will not have an explanation all you
will have is a description okay
mathematics can only describe an
equation is only a description of a
dynamic uh situation that's all you know
an equation is so all you have is a
description if you want an explanation
you won't find it in mathematics you'll
have to go to physics
and that's where the problem is because
the mathematicians have united or
extrapolated mathematical concepts into
physics and purport to explain how this
universe works by using mathematics by
using equations
but again all that is a description both
of them are housed
how something
works
meaning
how it works in the sense of how fast it
works how much time that's different
than saying how it works like what is
the mechanism those are two different
house
it's uh like if you hear you're talking
about the why and by why i don't mean
purpose and reason i mean cause and
mechanism so in that sense the y is not
a how okay and so those and wires they
get them mixed up constantly that's
that's the big problem so anyways uh no
an explanation is not a description and
description is not an explanation uh
explanation answers a question
okay so keep that in mind that is the
answer to his
rebuttal okay